Most people reckon that street art evolved from graffiti,...
...which fun fact has been going on for thousands of years.
Look, ancient graffiti.
That doesn't mean it's good.
In fact, most people would agree that graffiti is a bit of an eyesore.
But street art is another matter.
Over the years, some street artists like Jean-Michel Basquiat and Keith Harring...
...have become famous for their work, which started on public walls,...
...and then there's this guy, or maybe this guy, or is it this guy?
I dunno.
In fact, no one really knows who Banksy is.
But everyone knows his work.
Banksy started spraying his political-themed pieces in the UK in the 90s.
And since then, his work has appeared around the world.
Attracting thousands of tourists and sometimes selling for a lot.
Although you never know when this is going to happen.